giorgia say need 10 huh equals huh
gong-gong that's prince george's
adorable nickname for Queen Elizabeth
it's hard to believe that the little
royal is already 3 years old in honor of
Prince George's birthday we have a
roundup of his cutest moments yes Prince
William and Kate Middleton son has been
charming us since the pair introduced
their first child to the world in 2014
fast forward to two year old Prince
George and he was still making noise
here's the toddler throwing an adorable
temper tantrum before boarding a plane
at a military air show a bit fussy but
how cute is this shot of George taking a
seat in the cockpit of that jet last
week Prince George showed up to our
meeting in his bathrobe the little royal
even made a lasting impression on the
president who else can say they greeted
the Obamas in their pajamas whether he's
striking a pose for his first Christmas
photo at the Queen's 90th birthday
photoshoot front and center or at her
annual trooping the colour ceremony
showing us his best emoji face Prince
George always finds a way to adorably
steal the spotlight but it doesn't get
much cuter than when he became a big
brother the royal family shared a
priceless moment of George holding
Princess Charlotte at home and he hasn't
stopped watching over her since but
which Prince George moment was
absolutely too cute to handle I'm on
Twitter at tez know